Ngày 20,000 tháng tư tài khi đài tổ quốc bên giòn sông bến 2 cầu hình lương liệt sự.
Tình quần chỉ lóng trọng tổ chức lễ thượng cơ,
lế hội thống nhất nòn sông, khi biển 5 năm ngày giải phóng miệng năm thống nhất đất nước,
bà mấy tháng tư nằm mình chính trăm bể lâm, bà mấy tháng tư nằm ngày ngày hôm trong hay sấu.
Tham dự bười lễ có tổ mấy thơ, chủ tính nước tổ lâm,
chừng bán tổ chức chung ngương ngủyển duy ngọc, chừng bán nổi chính chung ngương lên mình chỉ
phó thu tự tưởng bội chường bộ quốc phòng phòng phòng văn văn văn văn văn văn văn văn văn,
bội chường bộ công an đường tham quan, phó thu tưởng chính phủ lế tiếng châu,
công các thành viên đoàn công tác chung ngương, lãnh đạo tình quảng chiế và đông đạo quần chúng nhân dân.
Trong cuộc ki trang nghiêm, lá cơ đó sáo văn dự dự ớ được kéo lên mình chỉ đại trên nền giá diệu
bài cuốc cá hủng trắng, bên dòng xong lix dự.
Đông chỉ tổ lâm, tổ bi thư chủ tính nước và các đại miểu đáng nhưng mình tưởng nhớ chủ tịch không chỉ mình bị đại.
Cái hủng lix dĩ và đông chỉ đồng bào đã hí xin vì được lập tự dò thống nhất tổ quốc.
Sau khi bình dơ nè vào năm 1929, xong bến hải tại vì tuyến mấy bài,
trở thành giới tuyến quân sự tạm thời với kì vọng sẽ tiến tới tổ tuyến cử thống nhất đơn nước.
Tuy nhiên, giói mưu và hình đồng phá hoại của đếc quốc Mỹ và chính quyền tây xai,
cho bình đã không được thực thi, khiến đơn nước ta phải chụ cảnh chứ cắt xuất 25 năm với nỗi đau nôn xong 2 nửa,
tổ quốc 2 miệnh. Trong buổi cạnh đó, khoảng chỉ cùng với quân và dân cả nước đã kiên cường bất quốc trên đấu,
bảo vệ vấn chắc giới tuyến ngàn trạm miêu mở giống chính xanh giá miếm bác.
Rưỡi mở bò bảo đảng của quân thu, lạc cơ trên kì đại hình lớn kiểu hãi tổng bây,
chờ thành biểu trưởng của nêm tiên và chỉ thống nhất của 2 miệnh năm bác.
Ngày sau lấy thượng cơ, tổ miếth thư chủ tính nước tổ lâm của bàn không tác,
đã ra dưới cầu hình lớn, gặp gỡ cử cánh bộ không ăn, bú trang, giới tuyến và học sinh.
Tham ra thả chỉ bộ cầu, chục ảnh như liệu.
Trong không khiến hoàn, đồng chỉ tổ miếth thư chủ tính nước tổ lâm và cánh đại biểu,
đã thả những cánh chi bộ cầu dưỡi nhập cầu nguyên lớn liệu.
Những cánh chiếm tổ máy, mang thông điệp về khách vọng phá bình của nử dân Việt Nam.